[Musique]
salut petit message d'abord pour toutes
les personnes qui sont en ehpad qu'on
peut pas visiter pour dire qu'on pense à
elle un grand merci à tout le personnel
soignant qui en ce moment on fait
quelque chose de formidable dont on leur
sera redevable pour très longtemps
encore et je voudrais dire que je très
simple pour lutter contre ce virus la
seule manière c'est de suivre les
consignes et de rester chez nous confiné
donc petit message tout simple re était
beau cazottes les t bonds caillebotte
bonjour les amis c'est malo christophe
je sais pas si vous souvenez de moi mais
j'habite il y être actif dans la lutte
contre le cancer
aujourd'hui je vous interpelle pour vous
puissiez respecter les règles de
confignon c'est très important
comme vous vous être asymptomatique
c'est à dire ne pas présenter de
symptômes mais quand même avoir la
maladie donc protégeons nous protégeons
notre famille nos amis
protégeons notre belle martinique
[Musique]